[Applause]
[Music]
okay wow what a happy crowd its people
of crazy I think I know why you're happy
because if Los Angeles gets nuked we
don't have to host the Olympic traffic
I'll be easy stuff so are you nervous
people are nervous people are nervous
everywhere not just here bill calls me
today sedated himself Cecily
I mean honestly between the nasty tweets
and the threatening statements and the
escalating rhetoric I mean tensions are
spinning out of control
and that's just between Trump and Mitch
McConnell I did but his little
perspective now the nuclear age began I
think this week it was August right
around this time in 1945 why'd you think
I was worth it when we dropped two bombs
called fat man and little boy and this
week it came full circle with a
different fat man and little boy
oh yes Donald Trump and Kim jong-un if
you haven't read about it are trying to
see who has the bigger micropenis I mean
that's what this is all about isn't it I
mean this whole conflict could be
resolved by two hookers willing to lie
that's all obviously and though I just
think some day these two [ __ ] are
going to bump into each other at the
Hair Club for tyrants and they're gonna
realize you know what we're not so
different you and I we both get out of
our golden bed in the morning and put on
our elastic waistbands hands one one
pudgy leg at the time it but Kim Jung on
if you're watching and I know he's a big
HBO fan not the blockbusters Treme he'd
loved John from Cincinnati wanted to
bring that back he's crazy anyway I just
want to say to Kim if you're watching
Dennis Rodman lives here here in now
any problem live here he's your friend
maybe your only friend and he lives here
he lives right in Newport Beach don't
[ __ ] with that but just to be safe since
it is Los Angeles is in the crosshairs
the government is telling us Angelenos
we should prepare an emergency survival
kit just the essentials a week's worth
of cronuts a selfie stick and a witch
it's better Jesse assesses levels of
government okay but you know it's
amazing that a week ago we weren't
thinking about this on this level this
all started because it was revealed that
North Korea succeeded in miniaturizing a
nuclear bomb that they could be placed
on a missile and now that they have
mastered that they're going to try to
figure out how to grow food so you know
once that news got out Trump responded
in his usual thoughtful Poissy way and
he said North Korea best not make any
more threats one that I met with fire
and fury like the world has never seen
hey mother of dragons we get it
you're a badass with nuclear weapons of
course knowing this administration the
launch code is probably password also
they've changed the hats it says make
America glow again that was worrisome to
me but wow she said I'd say only Donald
Trump could start World War three while
he's on vacation it's easy to forget
that oldest saber-rattling is happening
from a golf club
it's Caddyshack meets Apocalypse Now and
by the way general Kelly great [ __ ]
job keeping Trump under control that
really worked out well general Kelly oh
you did a great job no it was left to
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson six
months ago was head of ExxonMobil this
is the guy now I'm counting I'll just
stop the world from blowing up left to
him to try and walk things back Rex
Tillerson said the other day this is a
quote he said I think Americans should
sleep well at night I have no concerns
about this particular rhetoric of the
last few days yeah that's comforting in
other words nothing to see here people
president what does this button do was
just talking out his ass again I mean
how close does this toddler have to get
to dystopian the Republican Party picked
him up
plus I love this while all this is going
on this week Trump from his vacation
establishment got into the opium debate
he said he's going to end this he said
the opiate epidemic is a national
emergency and the opiate of Demick said
right back at you big guy